إنه لمن دواعي سروري البالغ أن أعلن عن
قفزة
فرصتنا
للقيادة
بالموهبة والتقنية التي
تقود بخفة الحركة والمرونة
لنتعاون معك لقيادة براغ إلى
المستقبل بآفاق جديدة ولكن لا عجب مرة أخرى
أن صاحب السمو الملكي
قال قبل ثلاث سنوات أن هذا هو  بالفعل أوروبا الجديدة
هذه هي فرصة النمو وتحت
قيادته وبالشراكة معك
أصبحنا
كمنطقة والأهم من ذلك كأمة
أكبر وأسرع اقتصاد رقمي
في المنطقة
وهذا دليل على قيادتك
عندما  يأتي إلى
أكبر سوق ، وهو إلى حد بعيد أكبر سوق بقيمة 40 مليار
دولار في التكنولوجيا والرقمية ،
وهذا هو الأكبر عندما يتعلق الأمر
بأبطال القضاء
والبطل الرقمي الأول من حيث صافي
الأرباح وقيمة العلامة التجارية آسف للجميع
هذه هي الأرقام  هي
scc وعندما نتحدث عن التكنولوجيا المستقبلية ،
فأنت تتحدث عن الشركة الوحيدة
في المنطقة التي تعهدت بتقديم مليار
دمية  آرس
نحو مستقبل
حلول الذكاء الاصطناعي المعرفية التقنية ، تكنولوجيا النيون
والرقمية
، وعندما نتحدث عن حالة الاستخدام ،
كيف يمكننا استهلاك هذه التكنولوجيا الموهوبة من
أجل الصالح العام
للكوكب والأشخاص الذين تتحدث
عنهم أكبر عميل تقني ورقمي
على وجه الأرض ،
كيف تستفيد أرامكو من
المواهب والتكنولوجيا للحفاظ على
الابتكار في قطاع الطاقة
لتصبح رقم واحد وتحافظ على
أقل تكلفة رفع عندما يتعلق الأمر
باستخراج النفط ولكن الأهم من ذلك
التركيز على تكنولوجيا المناخ والتكنولوجيا الخضراء
لتحقيق  تأكد من أن لدينا أيضًا
أقل كثافة للكربون وأنظف
أنشطة المنبع ،
فنحن الأعلى حتى الآن عندما يتعلق
الأمر بالمواهب التقنية
318000 وما زال العدد
لا يتعلق فقط بالكم بل
يتعلق بالجودة لأنه إذا نظرت بشكل أعمق
إلى هذا الرقم لدينا  قفزت من
نسبة 7 في المائة من مشاركة النساء إلى 28
، وهل يمكنني أن أحظى بجولة كبيرة من
التصفيق للسيدات في الغرفة
مع الشباب ، ولا يسعك إلا أن
نمضي قدمًا ،
لدينا واحد من أفضل 10
أجهزة كمبيوتر عملاقة ، لذا كمركز ثقل
لدينا مركز ثقل
لحساب المنطقة للسحابة ، لدينا أوراكل علي
بابا google sap والمزيد من الإعلانات الأخرى التي
تأتي بقيمة 2.5 مليار
دولار من الاستثمارات السحابية.
كما قامت
شركات التكنولوجيا العالمية هذه في أكتوبر الماضي
في حفل
الإطلاق بالإعلان عن مركز للابتكار أو
أكاديمية
حيث توصل المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي إلى المركز الرقمي الثاني
بتقرير يقول دعونا نلقي نظرة على الدول في
السنوات الثلاث الماضية التي صنعت أكبر شركة
رقمية  صعدت المملكة
واحتلت المرتبة الثانية بين مجموعة العشرين في المرتبة الثانية بعد
الصين
إذا تحدثنا عن نمو رأس المال الاستثماري ،
فقد نمت ثلاثة أضعاف أقرب منافس لنا
وتجاوزنا علامة 2 مليار الحقيقية
التي تتحدث عنها عن أسرع 10
اقتصاد رقمي نموًا في مجال التكنولوجيا المالية
الرقمية  المحتوى والتجارة
الإلكترونية وهذه مجرد بداية
لأننا بالشراكة معك
نفخر اليوم
بالإعلان عن
أكثر من 6.4 فاتورة  أيون ألف
استثمار
هذه الاستثمارات برعاية
وتوجيه صاحب السمو الملكي الأمير
محمد بن سلمان وبالشراكة
معكم
جميعًا سيتم الإعلان عنها على
المسرح من قبل مجتمع الأعمال ،
كل هذا أصبح ممكنًا
بواسطتك ولا يمكن أن تكون الأمور أفضل بالنسبة لـ
حدث لاول مرة
كنا نراهن على أننا سنصل إلى 40000
زائر ، لكنني علمت اليوم
أننا سجلنا بالفعل أكثر من مائة
ألف زائر مسجلين في هذا
الحدث وبفضل الرعاة المذهلين لكم
جميعًا على الشرائح امنحهم
جولة من  تصفيق من فضلك لا يمكننا القيام بذلك
بدون رعاتنا ،
هذا يقودني
إلى نهاية عرضي التقديمي
ولكن إلى بداية جديدة
حيث وعدتك قبل ثلاث سنوات
أنه بمجرد أن نتشارك في شراكة مدى الحياة
، وهذه بالفعل شراكة مدى الحياة
لقيادة قفزة  وترك الضفدع
في المستقبل ،
ما تبدو عليه الخدمة اللوجيستية الرشيقة
أنها بحاجة إلى محطات شحن جوي
ذكية نظام مستودع ذكي
فرز تلقائي
نظام التوزيع الذكي لمراكز جي روبوتات الطائرات بدون طيار
وغيرها من حلول التوصيل الذكية.
كيف تريد مشروعًا مشتركًا استراتيجيًا
في المملكة لتقديم
نفس التجربة
اليوم نود أن نقدم لك
للتعبير عن
قائد
لوجستي عالمي قائد لوجستي عالمي
أصبح
الشركة اللوجيستية الأولى في جنوب شرق
آسيا وواحدة من الشركات المزروعة في
سوق الصين
وهذا هو السبب في أننا فخورون جدًا
بأن نعلن مع ewtp Arabia
Capital والشركاء الاستراتيجيين الآخرين
أنهم يستثمرون أنهم
يخططون لاستثمار ما يصل إلى 2 مليار دولار
الدولارات
في سوق المملكة العربية السعودية في
السنوات العشر القادمة
[تصفيق]
جنبًا
إلى جنب مع
هذا المركز اللوجستي سوف يجلب المزيد
من مصنعي التكنولوجيا الفائقة في المملكة
وإلى المنطقة ، وهو ما يعد
علامة فارقة للمملكة ،
وهذا ما يجب اتباعه وتنفيذه
صاحب السمو الملكي
كرمريس محمد بن سلمان
[تصفيق
] معنا
أليس المدير العام لمؤسسة الكهرباء والاتصالات.
مكتب فكرة أبيا ولمعان الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة gnt
middle والآن سأترككم مع فيديو
من رئيس gnt group jet li
شكرا
[تصفيق]
صاحب السمو
، سيداتي وسادتي ،
أنا
مؤسس ورئيس مجلس إدارة dnt access
قررنا بدء
مقر شركة جيلي برس في الرياض في السنوات العشر
القادمة مع شركة ewtp Arabia
Capital وشركاء استراتيجيين آخرين ،
سنستثمر في الأجهزة والبرامج الأكثر تقدمًا
لتغيير
الفريق المحترف لبناء أكبر
مجمع صناعي لوجستي ذكي في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
المنطقة الوسطى اليوم تفخر شركة sdc بنشر
الأخبار حول
إنشاء أحد
معالمنا الرئيسية
للمضي قدمًا
بالاقتصاد الرقمي
إلى عصر جديد
اليوم ، فنحن نؤسس
مركزًا رقميًا لـ sdc mina يقوم بتوحيد مراكز البيانات
الكابلات البحرية
الكابلات الأرضية نقطة التواجد
عبر  حول العالم بالإضافة إلى النقاط الحدودية
، نتحدث عن متجر التوقف الجديد
للبيانات والاتصال الرقمي  إلى
المنطقة
خارج المملكة العربية السعودية
وإلى العالم الآن ، وبعد رؤية
تاريخ الابتكار والتكنولوجيا
والبناء
عليها ، يسعدني اليوم أن
أعلن قفزة كبيرة إلى الأمام تتجاوز أعمالنا
وإلى تعطيل تقنيات القرن الحادي والعشرين
التي يمكن أن
تخلق  عالم أفضل بالنسبة لنا غدًا ،
مشاريع الازدهار السبعة هي صندوق الاستثمار الاستثماري التخريبي الذي
تبلغ تكلفته مليار دولار
على مدى السنوات القليلة الماضية ، وقد
أنشأنا مكاتبنا في جميع أنحاء
العالم وبدأنا الاستثمار في
مجالات مهمة للمستقبل من
بينها التنقل
وكذلك medtech fintech و  العديد
من المجالات الأخرى ، كل هذه المجالات التي
نعتقد أنها
ستكون الاضطرابات الجديدة
، يعمل خبراء الاستثمار لدينا والمتخصصون
الفنيون والعلماء لدينا
معًا ليكونوا قادرين على
تحديد واستكشاف الاضطرابات الكبيرة القادمة
في العالم نحن
متحمسون للغاية ونفخر
بها  أعلنوا
عن أول
منصة لإدارة الموافقة على البيانات في العالم
meld
mel ببساطة شديدة
تسمح ذ  كمواطنين ، أنت كمؤسسات
أنت كمجتمعات لاستعادة السيطرة
على بياناتك واستعادة الثقة في
اقتصاد البيانات
، تقوم بذلك من خلال توفير
ثلاثة عناصر أساسية في
الأساس ،
أولها أنه يسمح لك بفهم من لديه
بياناتك
وما الذي يستخدمونه
ثانيًا ، يوفر
لك سوقًا لبدء
الفهم والتحفيز على استخدام
تلك البيانات للاشتراك أو إلغاء الاشتراك في تلك
التجربة النهائية
وثالثًا
لا تبحث بعد الآن حول مئات المواقع التي
تحاول معرفة ما
هي تفضيلاتك
التي تسمح لك بها  موقع واحد
باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي مع
توصيات
لتعيين معلمات الخصوصية الخاصة بك
بحيث يمكن تكرارها عبر جميع
مواقعك ،
لذا فإن
المزج بشكل أساسي
سيعيد الثقة إلى اقتصاد البيانات
حيث أسعدني يومًا بعد يوم أن أكون
محاطًا بمئات من الشباب
السعوديون المتحمسون المستعدون
لتغيير العالم بكل طريقة ممكنة من
خلال ابتكاراتهم في قسم
لدينا الموهبة  ولدينا
الشغف والتوقيت لا يمكن أن يكون
أفضل بالنسبة لنا لإطلاق وادي الشركات الناشئة الخاص بنا
في قلب مدينة
الرياض ، منطقة الابتكار حيث يمكن
لرواد الأعمال والمبتكرين من
أي مكان في العالم أن يجتمعوا معًا
لتحقيق أحلامهم وتحقيق أحلامهم.
إمكانات كاملة
مع ذلك ، إنه لمن دواعي سروري البالغ أن
أعلن
عن المرآب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذا أنا هنا على
المنصة لأخبرك أن المرآب ليس
رمزًا وليس شيئًا ، فالمرآب هو وسيلة
من الحياة
لذلك قمنا ببناء برامجنا في ثلاثة
مبادئ
مكانًا رائعًا لمشاركة المكاتب مع
مؤسسين عظماء
مكانًا لجمعه مع الآخرين
وأخيرًا مكان للتواصل مع الأشخاص المناسبين الذين
تحتاجهم ونطلق عليه
اسم المرآب
بالإضافة إلى
ذلك ،
دعني أخبرك لماذا  سيساعد انفجار المرآب
شركتك الناشئة
على النمو ،
فنحن نقدم كل ما تحتاجه من خدمات
المرشدين التدريبية لمكاتب منح البذور
من الشركاء وأخيرًا
التسويق ،
لكن المرآب يخدع
أكثر من
ذلك ويسعدني أن أعلن  اليوم
خمسمائة ألف سعودي
لكل شركة ناشئة في برنامجنا
شركاتنا ، والأهم من ذلك ، شركاتنا
المبتكرة الرقمية الناشئة ورجال الأعمال ،
أنا متأكد من أنك شعرت بالطاقة
والقوة التي
تأتي إلى قفزة أساسية
لإتاحة التكنولوجيا ، نشكر
حكومة  المملكة العربية السعودية لهذه
المساهمة ومنحنا تلك
المنصة لنا للالتقاء ومشاركة
أفضل ممارساتنا ومشاركة ما تعلمناه
وجعل المواهب متاحة
بالنظر إلى 70 في المائة من نمو
الاقتصاد سيكون مدفوعًا بالاقتصاد الرقمي
أيضًا 3.8 تريليون  سيتم
توفير الدولارات بالفعل من قبل الشركات
الناشئة.سوف تساهم الشركات الناشئة في 7
من أصل 10 وظائف
في العقد المقبل
اليوم وأنا فخور جدًا بأن أعلن
أننا نطلق جواز سفر بدء التشغيل dco ، سيوفر
جواز السفر
هذا طريقة أسرع
وأكثر كفاءة وأسهل
للعبور.  - حدود فتح منصاتنا
وإتاحة الوصول إلى الشركات الناشئة للتوسع
خارج الحدود مما
يفتح سوقًا بقيمة اثنين  تريليون
دولار ونصف مليار من
السكان سنتخيل معي
الفرصة المذهلة التي ستوفرها شركاتنا
الناشئة والمبتكرون الرقميون
للاقتصاد
ليس هذا فقط
ولكننا اليوم سعداء جدًا لأن القفزة
وفرت لنا منصة لدعوة 58 شركة
ناشئة من دولنا الأعضاء و
سيتم تزويدهم كمرحلة أولى بتصاريح
سريعة للتوسع إلى
مملكة البحرين والمملكة العربية السعودية
ونيجيريا
[تصفيق
] وهذا ليس كل ما
يسعدنا أن نأتي إليه وآمل أن نكون
متحمسين لأنك كذلك شكرًا لك.
كثير الشكر